hello everyone and welcome to the
ultimate showdown I'll be playing
against Magnus 11 and I'll be using
pretty much the same strategy I did
against H 10 just avoid any tricks in
the opening exchange pieces and go go
for for the endgame and try to spot
blunder says as much as I can so let's
see how the app deals with before okay
d5 proved to be a useful opening against
humans but we'll see now we'll see how
to really treat this opening
let's go Bishop d3 okay Roxy one
let's castle castle and now we we go
what
let's go night 95 he will grab the pawn
okay mmm I like it I like it so I guess
I go here captures I'll capture here
capture if I check him and queen h5 what
is that if I check him can get you a
teenage five that's pretty much winning
but but if I check in King g7
huh
have to be very careful here
or ignore everything and play queen h5
immediately
how does he stop Queen captures h7 it's
very interesting huh
how does he stop that
how does he stop queen h5 it's crazy
night-night of three trick that's crazy
okay I don't see how okay you can move
the rope but I mean that's still very
terrible okay I'm sure I'm missing
something terrible here so so let's just
see what I'm missing
h6 h6 does what exactly
tonight of three check okay ah now if I
capture with night I lose the Queen if I
capture with the point then Queen
captures with check very nice wow wow
that's some that's some resourceful
defense but if I play King each one what
then you're still getting checkmated
right King each one Knight captures oh
that's beautiful that's beautiful sir
seriously that that is beautiful
Wow
it's pretty unbelievable
see for night here now okay he opened up
the attack to my queen
[Music]
and watered an applic weenus three he'll
push d5 but an even worse thing is he
can bring the Queen back to the defense
Queen h4 Bishop g5 yeah that that Knight
is a beautiful piece right there okay I
guess I mean it's it's it's a nice game
but I'm still not completely convinced
it's go h3 I have five yeah I thought I
thought you might go for that it's a
much much more resilient move so how do
you stop checks now if I capture if I
capture you capture back and I don't
have time to capture and threaten rook G
424 Queens if if I capture he'll just go
yeah he can't push this pawn that's the
problem if he pushes it then he blocks
his queen
okay show me what I'm missing
f5 probably f5 is what I'm missing
it's like after a 5 but if f5 you you
block your queen again so I don't mind
at 5 Bishop g5 Wow
yeah now if I push a for adblock my own
rock if I play rock g4 I'm getting Aoife
yeah I still can't play e5 or he blocks
his queen you'll have to play f6 or
something and now a for now f4 and only
then will he push but again he blocks
his queen
[Music]
what a weasel
the push f4 he'll push d5 I capture
Bishop he captures rook I capture with
the Queen his queen is still cut off do
I go for this I'm down so much material
but man I really thought I had him there
but yeah it was a bit suspicious that he
would wonder such an attack that h6 was
was epic well out of order for Queen f5
huh
not allowing me to capture okay
queen h5 queen h7 captures captures
captures queen g7
I have to play g3 really if g3 Queen
checks kim jiwon g3 green checks Kings
yuan yeah okay show me show me
aiya
that's the stuff that's the stuff
huh
he's defending just just to good oh yeah
that's Wow
yeah okay okay you win so this is a non
access fluent attempt at defeating
Magnus 11 I really thought I had him but
that eight-six move was just just
awesome but yeah I guess engines don't
don't blunder games like that so yeah
that's it for this video thank you all
for watching and as against age 9 I will
have my revenge see you soon